and i want to welcome everybody to our
expert webinar today
applying lean principles in your work
and career with laura hendricks the
svp and director of enterprise rpa and
process improvement and quality at first
horizon bank
and
laura has just told me a short while ago
that first horizon is being bought by
dominion bank is that correct
laura
oh you're on mute i'm sorry
so there we go stuart it's td bank
toronto dominion bank
okay correct correct
okay
so
her life is a
constant whirlwind of excitement because
they just finished a merger with another
bank
last year so
um
today when you have questions for laura
please put them into the q a box
they will
we'll cue those up and we'll take them
in the
question and answer period at the end of
the webinar
so
we can have the conversation without too
much interruption but
we'll throw an eye over to the
chat and q a
during the of the
session but we will be queuing up the
questions so
please don't panic if we don't answer
them right away
and
we will have questions for you
and the first question
is
just pretty basic how much work
experience do you have
we're talking about general work
experience
since you graduated college
and if you haven't graduated yet um
let us know that too
the second question is um
checking in with you
we've been doing this throughout the
pandemic to see how people are
holding up under
rising and falling surges and lockdowns
coming and going and everything else
that happens so
like to see how people are doing
and we'll close the poll in about five
seconds
and
so we have a
experienced audience today laura the
two-thirds of the audience are people
with five or more years of experience so
um
that can give you some insight into who
we're speaking with and
uh it's good to see that
90 or so the audience
said that they are
doing well or at least okay
and for those of you in the third
category we hope that what laura has to
tell us today
will uh improve your outlook so
with that said
i would like to
give you a little background about laura
over 15 years of experience in
engineering and business
and
she specializes in in
helping
you know the the leaders of her
bank turn
their visions into reality and
helping your team
to support that
so
you're it's a
interesting process because it's
oops sorry it's
both the process improvement side but
also the automation side and those
things are
uh
intertwined inseparably so she'll talk
about that as we have our conversation
um
welcome laura
if you want to give a little bit more of
your background
thank you stuart it's it's great to be
here
um so i i'll give you the short version
on my background but i do
have an engineering background where i
did site development design
then
with economy changes i went to fedex and
worked at fedex in multiple roles
including their
quality driven management program which
is process improvement there and was
approached by first horizon bank to come
and stand up the programs here at first
horizon for the process improvement
program as well as the robotic process
automation programs
and i started out in the operations
that's where we stood up these programs
is in the back office operations of the
bank
and stuart mentioned that we've recently
completed a migration which was uh
subsequent to a merger of equals with
iberia bank and when that happened
i was promoted to to lead the enterprise
rpa process improvement programs for the
the joint banks we did just complete our
system migrations in february and
anybody that's been through that no it
is not for the faint of heart
to go through that and right at the end
of it on february 28th it was announced
that we have been acquired by td bank
which is uh takes us back into a
whirlwind
that being said we feel very
very prepared to go into this next stage
of changes and challenges that we're
going to go through especially because
we had just gone through that migration
and and in fact we were we were still
winding down on some of that you always
have some
uh
some uh
some
task after migration that you're gonna
have to clean up etc and so so we've
been doing that at the same time of
refocusing and reinventing of what is
our new norm looking forward to being a
part of td bank so
our uh our objectives for our coming
year in the next year have changed since
that announcement but uh we we do feel
better prepared
to help the entire bank
and
go through these changes and it you know
it is
it's difficult uh for employees
to
to just close one book looking forward
to a little breather and then go back
into another one uh so my team is here
to to help them we uh we were able to
really
expose ourselves to a lot of different
departments during this last migration
they began to learn what we could really
do with process improvement and with
automation
and help them out and we did indeed help
out a lot of different departments and
now that they're starting to regain
their footing and they're also starting
to look at the vision of where they need
to go over the next year they're they're
continuously reaching out to us to help
them and and help really build some
capacity creation
because in order to do these migration
activities
you're pulling on the same employees
that have their day jobs and so they're
reaching out to us and that's that's
where a lot of our focus is going now
stuart and uh we're we're excited we're
excited about what what we can continue
to do
for the employees of the banket and the
customers to uh make these changes uh
we're also excited by the way by the the
acquisition and having uh bigger
platforms and more products and
offerings for our customers so looking
forward to it yeah and you know
acquisition and mergers used to be uh
and still are of course you've just gone
through it um it's a huge challenge but
in the past
there are actually uh examples of
companies that
almost went under because of the
challenges of just merging the two
different
data processing systems back in the day
when it was called data processing
and
that
that kind of environment has changed now
with
the the more
rigorous understanding of lean
principles agile principles um some of
the folks on this column may not be
familiar with lean
can you describe
what it is in your world
um yes lean is basically looking at your
processes
and in identifying where the waste areas
are and getting rid of the waste and
that in increa improves your efficiency
when you get eliminate that waste um we
go about it in in a methodology that
with a lot of training a lot of lessons
learned from a lot of people that
preceded us in the the lean world but
you can look at different categories of
waste one of the acromegs that's
typically used is tim woods um t is for
transportation that's an interesting
thing because if i first began my lean
training at fedex and that's how they
make their money right transporting
stuff
from one one place to another location
but we were trained that that that is
that you need to try to eliminate that
or at least make it more efficient for
people so transportation excess
inventory is the i m is motion walk into
printers um delivering papers all that
kind of thing
the the w is waiting when you're waiting
for approvals or you're waiting for the
products you need to to be able to
produce you're just sitting there
waiting uh the first o is overproduction
if you're if you're producing more than
you need to
uh second o is over processing if you're
if you're
have more strict uh
more strict guidance on your uh what
you're having to do
uh or if you're if you need eight pages
in a report but you're including 40
that's over processing uh you can
identify those and and i'm not going to
tell those tricks but
i've got to know that people are
actually looking at them or not but
we'll be happy to explain that offline
sometime but uh you can identify people
are actually looking at what you're
producing all the time the the d is for
defects we all know that defects we have
to go back rework
and uh so that's double work and it's
also frustrating for the employees and
for customers
uh the s is uh the s waste is skills and
that's under under utilizing the skills
of your staff
so those are some of the areas of ways
that are traditionally looked at now
when i came to the bank and stood up the
process improvement program here and
it's based on lean and six sigma uh some
on
baldrige and a little agile mix in but
um i i changed that acronym to to mr tim
p woods and
always got more ways but when you
combine in automation what you start
looking at is
what are you what is your staff doing
that's manual and repetitive if it's
manual and repetitive look at it and see
if it actually needs to be done and if
it has to be done really strongly
consider automating that task if it's um
if it's rules-based and there and the
staff is just doing these things things
repetitively over and over and over
again that is prime for for robotic
process automation and take a look at
that because it's it is a waste to have
humans sitting there doing something
that a bot can do and we can have the
humans going on to
speaking nicely to our customers etc uh
the p in the middle is printing believe
it or not there's still a lot of
printing that goes on it companies
a lot of it's habit some of it may be
thinking that you have to
print then you have to file it then you
have to store it for a certain amount of
time but in today's digital age
obviously that that's not needed and so
those are some of the other areas of
waste so again
lean is identifying those waste
and
getting rid of those waste
and the all that time and that money and
those resources that you save when you
do that can now be used for full
production and your efficiency goes up a
lot uh the the satisfaction from
customers and employees when you lower
defects etc and and and stop all the
waiting time
it is phenomenal um
you can see it almost immediately
i've i've done process reviews and
process mapping where there's been six
different levels of approvals
and so you can imagine if you know a
couple of those levels are on a week
vacation in there that extends out that
waiting a long time so uh you can get
rid of a lot of of wasted time
yeah it's it's uh
always frustrating when
things have to go up but higher than the
necessary level of approval for you know
that just last example you mentioned but
you were talking about
the state of lean today and it
makes me think of how we've evolved to
this point i've had a
a good friend who has a company that
is
basically used the theme war on waste
for
a couple decades now
and
that kind of thinking is has been
codified into lean
but also when you talk about quality i
mean
we had
back in the 80s we were hearing
the
idea quality is free phillip crosby
and the idea that
um
if you do it right the first time
you will
eliminate the need to do it over you
will eliminate the need to tell the
customer why you didn't do it right the
first time and
you know all the other things that fall
out of that
equation so
the notion of quality is free is the
idea that
you know whatever you invest in quality
you'll make back
many folding
savings not just of your time and
resources but also
lost customers on the one hand and new
customers who are attracted to the
quality on the other
um
and
so
extending that principle beyond the idea
of the quality of the product to the
quality of everything that you do within
the company
is a
a big evolution over time um
now you
your job is
to apply the lean principles
robotic process automation in the bank
to its processes
to make
things more efficient to make the
products
higher quality
the customer interactions
uh better
how have you also then applied those
principles to your team you have the
robotic process automation center of
excellence within the bank
and
it itself is an operation that can be
you know the mr timpy woods principles
can apply to and how have you done that
it's it's been a very interesting
journey because of being a process
improvement expert and
after we got the rpa program
stood up i started realizing that that i
hadn't applied those principles to my
own rpa program
and so what what had happened one of the
key elements in when you're trying to to
make sure a process is
optimally efficient is you have to
standardize you absolutely have to
standardize it starts with folder
structure uh on in through processes and
procedures uh but you have to
standardize what i learned pretty
quickly uh we my my team
uh now expands from california to
bangalore india and
what what i first notice is is the the
file folders it's very simple right but
the file folders from from one developer
from another their code would be
named this in a folder or or their uat
would be in another folder etc and it
was just
way out away from lean if we did we
weren't standardized it was going to be
an utter mess if we didn't get it
straight because you're going to have
turnover particularly when you have
contractors etc and then you have that
overlap of time of where you've got
offshore time and onshore time and and
developers need to be able to go quickly
to their resources and not have to do a
lot of hunting around in folders that
was one of the first things we did as
simple as that sounds is develop our um
eight eight folder uh structure for our
rpa team uh so the the process
definition documents go in in that in
the that folder the code goes in this
you know folder the uat goes in the uat
folder that the change orders go in the
change order folder and the packages go
in the package or
folder and again as simple as that
sounds unless you institute it and you
make sure that it's done it will not be
done so fortunately i saw this pretty
early on uh when and we had we got a
project and we we took all the existing
folders and we transitioned them to our
existing file folder structure
moving on down the road
as we developed we also developed
templates the the user acceptance
testing templates we added to them a tab
with a checklist for code reviews so we
could standardize the code review
because the code review onshore was
different than the code review offshore
and we needed it all standardized so we
put that in there
we
created a form that's completed when
there's a migration to production that
gives all the information about
what the change was that was being made
who's requesting it
etc what assets are needed um all that
so we did all this standardization and
then we we kept looking at it in in
asking for brainstorming from our team
and we've gotten so much great
information but but we went on from that
to now
even all our folders we have a
a template folder
and within each of the eight folder
they contain the other templates that
are needed for that stage in rpa so the
the pdd folder has the pdd template
the you know the code folder
it has has the config file template in
there uh the uat folder has the uat
template in there and the change order
folder has the change order request
template in there so when the business
analysts now go to create these folders
they're not sitting there manually
creating them and then everybody else on
the team is manually going back to the
template folder and grabbing this
template and putting in there and
grabbing that template and putting in
there we have it one place they they
copy it
they paste it put the name of the
automation on there and everything they
need is right there in that folder so
that's that's a real basic simple uh
uh
example of what we did but we also went
on from there so
we we realized that
in their coding
the there were a lot of similar codes
that not that needed to be uh put in
like uh to access mainframe uh and so
we wanted it just to be a grab-and-go
plug-and-play type setup so we had the
developers start creating custom
activities that we have in our in our
library we also have multiple
automations
that are subsequent to some of our
standard automations but for instance
we have a logging automation that our
automations
each of our individual automations will
put what needs to be logged into the
logging queue
we have a separate automation that picks
it up and puts it in the business log
and puts it in our official audit logs
and so
that that's outside that's very standard
as we as we progressed on
we realized and this is continuous
that's one thing about past is
improvement right it never ends and
that's why they call it continuous
process improvement so as we continued
on even with for example the the logging
automation you have some automations
that were processing thousands of
transactions and they clogged up the
log queue and so we created different
levels of high volume logging q low
volume log and q so that those that had
20 that the business need to see right
away didn't get caught behind a thousand
that they could wait and so uh those are
just some of the examples of what we've
done to to standardize within the rpa
coa we're continuing to do that as a
matter of fact we um
we
continuously look at what are our
questions that are coming back from our
developers that keep coming back to the
business analyst
and it's a lot of them are access
questions etc and so we're working on
improving our templates for on the front
end to capture that information so we
don't have that waste on the back end
that that's going to be asked and then
we're going to have to wait uh to get
the the information back from the
business unit so so those are some
examples stewart of what we're what
we're doing i we're able to accomplish a
lot more with a lot less but we're also
able to get our turnaround time very
quickly and and that's that's essential
when you're going through a migration or
a merger because you need to be able to
help people quickly
yeah it's also
really essential in a heavily regulated
industry like banking
because you never know when the next
big
law is going to come out or regulation
it's going to come out like
sarbanes-oxley or something like that
that's going to require
you to change
all sorts of ways that you do business
to meet that new standard right
right i think it simplifies changes like
that a whole lot because
again we're standardized so if if we
need to make this change we know where
we need to make it
or if it's multiple points where the
multiple points are we recently
right after the migration and the
acquisition announcement we we
experienced our first internal audit
wow that's fun
it really was a pleasure because i've um
i work very
collaboratively with the audit team and
the compliance and socks and everything
so i i mean i approached it and i told
my teammate we we need to learn
from them we you know give them
everything they they want we gotta
listen and and improve upon it um i
think that working collaboratively all
this time that for these past three
years uh was
just very very instrumental in helping
us
come through that audit you know with
with flying colors and also we knew
we when we were asked for we had this
spreadsheet of all the the ask of of the
information they needed knew exactly
where to get it and and provided it back
and so that helped a whole lot no no
hunt and peck and try to find and all
that kind of thing going on so that was
very helpful
it's it's uh
you know it's
when we talk about
you know
banking environment being subject to
audits and that type of thing that's
kind of a generally applicable
idea now out in
the world that our
audience is in
people are working in for example
digital marketing
now have to worry about
the gdpr
regulations uh
from
europe about privacy of
data and
the things that you used to be able to
do
you can't do anymore
um but
even beyond that if you're
using
google analytics as part of your
suite or if you're if you're using um
google's uh
advertising services and
digital marketing services
you have no idea how the algorithms are
changing so
you have to be
responsive
to changes that you don't even know are
happening
and
it's
an interesting exercise in in being
agile and applying the the principles of
you know our if our operation is
organized around lean principles
and that gives us the ability to respond
quicker without it
wasting
time and resources on unnecessary tasks
we have more
ability to respond to these
challenges and changes in our
environment and adapt to them
is that
would you say that that's a generally
applicable
principle across you know pretty much
all digital industry
i i really i can't speak for all the
digital industries but i would i would i
would think so yes i just know in in
working with all the different
departments that i work with the
different teams i work with and the
challenges
that they have
when they have let's say 20 different
people
and the 20 different people are doing
something 20 different ways and someone
comes in and asks for
something they get answers like well it
depends on if mary's doing it or if
john's doing it if mary does it it'll be
there if john does it it'll be there and
you see where it starts going around and
it becomes extremely inefficient and
frustrating by the way other people
the people asking for the information
and so um i think it i think it
would be applicable certainly i think
even you know in smaller businesses the
same application can apply
if you if you have standard standard
processes it's sort of uh like when you
walk into your house at night if you lay
your keys different places uh every day
you're going to spend time
going to search for your keys and
instead of just having a place you put
your keys when you come in then you know
you go get your keys there same type of
principle of standardizing make
something a routine and um
then you know where to go
to get something but you also know where
to go to adapt something uh and
troubleshooting is in there you know in
a digital world right that's that's part
of everyday life uh in in the robotic
process automation side of the house is
monitoring and troubleshooting and so
having these lean principles of waste
and standardization
we we have definitive processes that we
go through when there are issues and
things that we look at uh and we can go
back to our resources of our logging our
standard logging etc and track down
pretty quickly
where we might be able to fix something
yeah
um
so
where are i i think
is this the time that you wanted to ask
the audience about their personal
position in the uh rpa journey
yeah
that's great
let me um
bring up that poll for people
and
i'll also put it on the screen in a
moment but
there's a couple of questions that laura
would like to ask you about
uh
where are you in your your career
journey in lean
and
where are you in your career journey
with the
rpa robotic process automation
so let me pull that up
so
let the pole go for a few more seconds
okay and three two
one
here's the responses
so
in rpa
about 40 percent of the audience hasn't
started but
the rest of the audience is
in that
journey right now
whether they're the the beginning of the
journey or whether they're
far along in it
um
in lean uh
it's people are tend to be farther along
there's fewer people who said they
haven't started yet
and
can you then
tell us about
where
you see the bank going in its journey
and in your maybe in your personal
journey
yeah i i i alluded to some of the
changes we're looking at now in our
direction uh prior to the acquisition
announcement our our plans for 2022 post
migration was really built out our our
citizen developer program uh for for rpa
and and also to to keep uh improving our
efficiencies with the rpa department for
our lean program we also had had plans
of of spreading out into the enterprise
and um taking on some bigger end-to-end
process improvements the more the more
challenging ones a lot of times
what you have in especially large
enterprises is you have a silo effect
and so you have these different teams in
these different departments and all
these silos have to connect together and
they don't do it as efficient as
efficiently as it can be done if you
look at it from an end-to-end uh view
and and get those processes improved we
have we've turned that back around now
because we really don't want what we're
calling throwaway work we don't want to
to spend the next six months on
something on the process that's going to
go away uh the quarter the first quarter
of 2023
and so for our uh journey with um i'll
talk speak to lean first we have several
very large process improvements that
have been underway that that are
continuing we're continuing to add uh
that that benefit to different teams in
the bank
those that are still applicable we are
continuing on with those uh and really
focusing on those again to give those
teams that that lift that they need so
we we have those improvements going on
we're looking very cr with a very
critical eye when we're seeing these
come in of
is there time left as we are to see the
benefit from continuing on and if they
are then we're continuing on if not then
we're taking our resources in and
looking at the other areas that we will
be able to get that interim uh benefit
from our resources so that we're not
just just wasting our resources so um on
the lean side that's where the direction
we're headed on the lean side on the rpa
side as i alluded to before we are
having a lot of the teams come to us and
helping us uh
help getting us to automate different
tasks and processes they have
we and that's in addition to the ones
that we already have
that are running in production
i anticipate that over the next i'd say
six months
that we're going to see a lot more of
that of those type of requests coming
into us
so that these teams can take those
manual repetitive tasks off their
employees so that those employees will
be freed up in q1 of 2023 when we go up
to to actually uh start with this act
full into this acquisition
i i have a
a question and i think it relates to one
of the questions that has come in but
and we'll talk about it maybe more in
the q a but
um
a preliminary discussion
you have people on your team that you
hire because of
their expertise in lean and process
improvement and then you have people on
your team that you hire
because they have expertise in
coding software development
using the tools
for that latter
category how do you
bring them up to speed with
understanding
lean principles
and and
becoming proficient in
and part of the culture
of your
center of excellence
that's this interesting because i don't
do it in a straight
straightforward these are lean
principles and and this is this is what
we're doing because um the rpa coe
program is here and the the lean process
program is over here that what they what
they do learn though is the identifying
the difference uh
in it in that when we're asked to do an
automation
and let's say for our business analysts
they start talking to the to the
business and we have some that are in
flight right now
but that they they talk to the business
and they find out well we get these
requests and they come in from
individuals in all different formats um
in outlook and so they they recognize
that well we have to go to the lean side
we have to go to the process improvement
side and get that front-end process
improved and so they they know to put
this over
to us on the process improvement side
and let us get that front-end
standardized and improved so that we can
then automate on the back end as far as
our culture in our rpa coe
we meet we we meet we talk
um
very very frequently even though we're
from california to bangalore india we we
have a a culture of collaboration and
camaraderie on our team that preceded
covid
so prior to covid we we met virtually
with our cameras on
once a month for our bot builders
virtual social and we visited it and we
developed that culture of getting to
know one another um getting back to the
the lean
portion of it in in process improvement
we also have monthly lessons learned
that are again
global of a global nature from
california to bangalore and we get on
and uh share the lessons learned so that
we can repeat those
during our uh we have
bio we have twice a week we have scrums
global scrums with the offshore and
onshore developers and the bas and
during those scrums we have even uh done
the process improvements of we have
when we go through the scrums so we have
the percentage complete they know
they're going to be asked certain
questions we finish in 15 minutes one
you know we're done with that um then
when we when we start looking at our
solution designed uh we have a weekly
solution design review
and we we look at that of of
streamlining it and getting waste out of
out of the designs even before they go
to development so it's not so much a
focused training of we're going to train
you on lean
as it is embedded into our culture as an
rpa coe excellent
yeah um you told me an anecdote in one
of our conversations about
a case of over processing it at fedex
and i bring it up because
you just talked about how you
streamlined your scrums to be done in
15 minutes
you need to tell me about the experience
you had with the
150 page report
that
it had to be presented to people every
every month yeah
yeah so so that was it fedex okay now
that steward is getting in here he's
digging on in because he's wanting me to
tell my tricks right but
but this is applicable so we had it was
about 170 slides and basically the main
core of it was 35 or 40 um slides it
with the red yellow and
and green uh dashboards that you know
just stuck out at the executives and
that's what the executive want to see
but then back in the appendix there are
all these hundred
hundred or so slides that are intricate
you know uh metrics and
i had to do the quality control on it
and all these
if you ask people if they're if they
need something they're going to tell you
they need something here's the trick
you just and i was told this but i'm not
going to say who uh but but uh this
trick is
we would have the date that these slides
were updated and so if it's if it's may
of 2022 we'd say you know updated april
10th
2022. um and so
when we suspected that this information
was not being looked at by anyone
we would um go a month and not update it
and then we go two months and still not
updated now three months is three months
old nobody's noticed we just pull it out
and uh if somebody
needed it certainly you know we we would
put it back in but it was a pretty good
sign of being able to know that nobody
is looking at this uh stu as as long as
stuart's pulling this out of me
i did a weekly report uh for two years
once in engineering that no one ever
asked for and so
i think in most people's worlds when you
bring up these kind of things they can
go back into their world and realize
that there are some things that they do
uh that that aren't not that nobody is
looking at and so you have to start
looking at what why are we doing this
and how can we determine if they really
are again if you ask people if they're
looking at your great report you send
out they're going to say they are but
but are they really you know so so
get creative and figure out if they're
really looking at it or not
yeah and then
the
thing that you just mentioned why are we
doing this
is
is really one of the most important
questions you can all you can ask
when you're looking at you know
streamlining your processes and and
eliminating waste is because you you
often will hear the answer because we
always did it that way
because
somebody who is here started doing it
that way and we just decided that that
that must be the way it's supposed to be
done and no one's ever thought about it
beyond that and
you know it's your job in the
you know the the
lean program for the bank and in the rpa
program to think about why are people
doing this and and
is this something that serves the
purpose of of the bank and its customers
or is it just something that
you know upholds a
strange ritual or a tradition that you
know
among the people inside the bank so
um
stewart we have a tool in our lean
toolbox called the five wise you know
and and when i'm training people that
that are in lean and and you get that
type answer why why are you doing this
this way because that's the way it's
always been done well you got to go a
lot farther than that you know why why
why why
and a lot of times it's outdated and you
don't need to do it at all you know it
doesn't need to be improved it just
needs to be obliterated right
yeah
um
i'm going to mention one example i think
that
illustrates
how
pervasive
how far-reaching the
idea of
quality and
um
lean processes can go and and this is
kind of an odd example but it's from
baptist hospital in memphis tennessee
and
it's one of the
knowledge should be one of the highest
quality
health care systems and
the ceo likes to show a film of
how everyone in the hospital is involved
in delivery of health care
and one of the segments in that video is
one of the housekeepers
and
you know what's your job here
and the housekeeper says my job is to
create a
clean and pleasant environment in which
the patient can heal
and
that's
um
you know if you look at most people when
they look at an organization chart or
they think about job functions they
think about the tasks that people do
but
it's important to understand
why those tasks are happening and what
the bigger purpose is that the for the
organization that those tasks fulfill
because if you don't know why you're
doing something
and you're just doing it repetitively
like like you said if it's a manual
repetitive process
that you don't understand a purpose
behind
you're not going to really pay attention
to the quality of it but if you
understand the purpose
you can
even do things like
well
you know what i've always thought if we
did this
different tool or if we took this
different step
we could do it better and those kinds of
improvements can flow up from
you know from the production floor all
the way up to the top of the
organization
so
with that in mind you know what are some
of the ways that
lean principles can help
people in the audience improve their
value
um in their work and their
potential value to their current or
future employers
um
or in in
other
career paths that they might choose
i'll just um i'll just tell you what how
it's helped me in my career is when i
first began to learn about lean of
course i was an individual contributor
so i had control over
my desk
part of my desk right
but but how not what i did but but how i
how i did some in some areas and so i i
knew that that i couldn't control what
was going on out the rest of the
enterprise or the the company but i
could control my own work and my own
throughput and in how i conducted myself
during the day to get that done as i
started applying some of these lean
principles of standardizing of
eliminating waste of simplifying and my
my throughput went went up a lot and
when i first started doing it i was
working in the engineering works world
so i was billable by the hour
and particularly for projects that were
a set fee project
i could do it in less time
than somebody else could because of
these standardizations and these waste
eliminations and so
that that improvement literally improved
my value from a dollar standpoint
as i when i went to fedex and i had
certain you know tasks i had to do by
deadlines etc and i've applied the same
principles of eliminating the waste and
performing those tasks
i was able to get those done
with less errors more efficiently if i
was
asked for a report impromptu
because i did some very very archaic
type automations with just what we had
but
i was able to turn that back around
quicker so again
improving that value as an individual
contributor then of course a as is you
go on and into management and you start
at looking at your teams and other
departments uh
again
you're able to we look at it as a total
economic impact
and
there's five different parts of that
first of all there's the uh
rate of uh return on investment which is
your easy to figure out dollar signs i
say five hours and it's so much an hour
then i've saved you know such-and-such
amount those are the straightforward and
that's usually what a lot of people look
at but but you also have to look at when
you're looking at the total economic
impact of what you're doing and how
you're improving processes you have to
look at improving employee satisfaction
such as decreasing turnover
that's very hard to measure but you can
get it from surveys and just
observations i feedback customer uh
experience improvement is big that's
also hard to
monetize sometimes but that's that's
important the elimination of errors and
defects uh that that's part of your
total economic impact because you're not
having to rework it in a world like ours
you're not getting fines and penalties
um etc applied to these these processes
and then lastly which is one that we are
what we look at a lot especially now
going through this past merger and with
this acquisition coming on is that the
capacity creation
and so
if you if you're doing these process
improvements and or the automations and
you're
and you're uh increasing the amount that
can be done with the same amount of
staff or less then your value has just
gone up in your company
uh i know
in most industries today we're
challenged in backfilling and getting
staffing and uh
there's turnover and then in some cases
uh people are hired even on a contractor
basis they get another job before they
even come
etc and so we're having to be more
efficient we're having to to get our
work done and get it done better with
less resources and so i think in those
ways whether it's at your desk level or
a management level um hopefully that
will be able you'll be able to see that
the value you create for for your
enterprises
great
um
as you were
mentioning
the customer experience
i think one
specific
example of a pull forward of how
lean principles can apply
in another area that we don't
necessarily think of it
but in ui ux design using user
experience and user interfaces
understanding
what is important for the user to see
and what fulfills the
tasks that they're trying to to to
accomplish with your application versus
what's
useless or wasted time or distracting or
that type of thing
um that's really
an important aspect of that practice so
that
what you create
is
a
pleasant and delightful experience for
the customer rather than a frustrating
one where they have to do
extra steps or
fill in information that
they don't really think is necessary for
them to share
or
you know that you're that they know
you're not going to use
and so that
i think is
a kind of a direct example of how
acquiring knowledge and understanding of
lean principles
can be applied you know in another area
in addition to the
the
areas that you talked about so
um
i think we're at a point in our
conversation where it's time to take up
some questions from the audience and
we've got a few that are
lined up we've got
see if i can get this
to appear on my screen
[Music]
uh
rheem asks a very general question but
it's a it's a great question which is
how do you
know
where in your business processes you
should improve so that you can get happy
customers in a successful company
that that i'm asked that a whole lot uh
you know where where do you start
and the number one and something that
you alluded to uh stuart is the the
customer defines the quality
and so
ask your customer or listen to your
customers when they're coming to you and
they want something or they have a
complaint or whatever listen to that and
start with your customers quality you
absolutely have to focus on
the customer and what they want now that
being said as you get into
the internal part of an enterprise
you get all those different nuances and
the internal processes going on so uh
what i tell people is is where you start
is you just you start by making a list
and it's how i started uh here at the
bank
and it's how i recommend other people to
start uh you make a list of first you
make a list of what are all the
opportunities people will start coming
to you and go i've thought about doing
this and and this process needs to be
improved and
make your list but you know so write it
down
uh put put in there who told you that
believe it or not when you start getting
a lot of them you you forget who told
you what and suggested what but but
that's how we started out and how i
started out with the bank and then on
that beginning list i began to see well
some of it needs to go to a process
improvement and some of it's just manual
and repetitive has to be done it's
essential and that just needs to go to
rpa
and so with that initial list to see we
started saying rpa process improvement
we started
getting that lined out
from that came our two separate list of
opportunities one is for the lien
process improvement and one is for the
rpa
and we use that
to this day
of we put the opportunities identified
on those lists and then we have a
prioritization process that we go
through in different phases that we go
through
of assessing what they are
what the impact is is it customer
experience improvement employee
experience improvement capacity creation
roi uh error prevention uh et cetera and
we and we go through that we prioritize
these up through these lists
and that's how we keep our pipelines
going but it all starts out with that
one start with that one essential list
and decide is it process improvement
lean process improvement needed or is it
automation improvement name now that
that being said we had some that were
both yeah uh in our back office
operations we had an immediate need to
take this manual repetitive off
and we had this longer-term need of
improving a process from from start to
finish and so we gave them the lift and
back office operations of automating
what they were having to currently do
and at the same time doing that longer
term process improvement
free just asks about
applying lean principles in a startup
environment
where the changes are very rapid
where
you don't have a lot of time to deal
with things now can you
kind of compare that to
the
kind of time crunches that you end up
with in
you know in the bank and things like
coping with deadlines for mergers and
you know other types of of important
time down processes
yeah i i can um and you know it's
interesting you know with the startup
and and it's going rapidly and a lot of
processes are being put in place at one
time and they had to be put in place
simultaneously and and all the wheels
are going and everything uh that that in
some ways is very similar to standing up
two programs even though it was at 150
year old bank brand new you know
everything was going fast he had to get
this turned around and starting it
what what the way i would address it on
in a startup is
is to to look at the the the
standardization portion of it
and also um what what is essential
whether it's a startup or an enterprise
is is having your backup plans uh in
contingency plans for business
continuity if if a particular entity
left
in startup if you you don't want
this person to leave and all that
knowledge of
theirs go out the door and how this
process is going on so it's it's very
critical there too so i would look at
standardization and making sure that
that there's some documentation in place
so that you can have your business
continuity going on if so if an entity
was sick or uh left and went decided
they didn't like the startup
and left that you don't have this
gigantic hole
going on there but
that goes back to a lot of the the lean
principles of of standardizing
documenting um and you know
looking at it from a waste waste uh
standpoint don't don't even start a
process that you're gonna
be uh
you know manual and repetitive if you
can avoid that particular process do it
if you can buy an out-of-the-box
software that does it for you then you
eliminate having to go back later and
change it
is that into that stuart
yeah and that that leads into another
question that
you had which is
um how easy is it to adopt
rpa i mean is is it something that you'd
recommend
you know
training up in-house talent to do it or
going with an
outsourcer
what situations
would those two different scenarios
apply
yeah we did we kind of did a hybrid of
those two so uh we had consultants come
in four consultants on site for nine
weeks to help us work with the different
stakeholders and stand up our program
and the policies and procedures etc and
then
when they left we trained uh
two in-house people to do do automations
what we found with that was our demand
was so much heavier on our time
that we could not take the time to
continue to train in-house so i think
that's got to be a lot of the decision
of of what you decide to do is how much
how much time and how much money do you
have
if you and also the the skill set of
your in-house talent do they have the
skill set where they can can learn
rpa
and uh and apply it and then are they
going to be there to monitor and
maintain it so
i i think it depends on the like i said
the level of what you've got in-house
uh what your demands are going to be if
you've got a lot of different demands on
your time you're not going to want to
take the time to to
bring your your developers up from
ground zero up
i know as we as our program has grown
even when we've looked at when we got to
be
between 40 and 50 automations in
production uh then we had to look at how
much time our monitoring was taken just
you you don't these aren't one and done
situations you don't automate something
and and they're out the door and that
they're there for life you you you have
to monitor them in production if
something fails you have to go in and do
troubleshooting etc so when we started
growing and we were looking at that same
question of do do we want to build our
monitoring team in-house and maintain
that in-house or do we want to outsource
that and bring it in what we had to look
at
was the time that our existing team did
we didn't have the time to go train that
monitoring uh
person and then what happens if they're
on vacation then we had to pull
developers or somebody else in to
monitor for them if they leave then we
have to pull our resources from all our
different areas so and that decision we
we outsourced that monitoring and still
do so i think that's a lot some of the
decisions that that have to be made
is uh what you know what
what you're actually the scale you're
looking at
and what you anticipate as coming in and
and i think you have to stay um
adaptable you know like i said we
started out one way
and realized pretty quickly that we were
going to have to grow a different way
our model has worked out well we have
some in-house developers we have some
contracted developers we have
right now our business analysts are
in-house but we have supplemented them
during the migration with um resource
outsourced uh business analysts
are monitoring is outsourced and so i
think you just got to always be aware of
what your supply and demand is
on your internal resources if if you
don't keep that in mind when you're
building your model and just making
these decisions and and if you don't
stay
adaptable and agile in
the ability to be able to change how
your model works
as you grow
in your demand on your time for
monitoring enhancing
even once a year you have software
upgrades and all your automations in
production have to be tested before that
is done if you don't stay in an
adaptable framework and continuously
reviewing what your program is doing you
could go belly up
yeah
um
i think what you've talked about just
addressed a lot of the question did you
ask about the
the you know doing a kind of a build or
buy decision between
automating a process with with a custom
automation or
looking for
a product on the market that'll do the
same thing for you
um
by the way do you have a shoe she also
have one comment she says she's going to
use your tip about the legacy deck and
not updating it
because she also has a legacy deck that
has a lot of useless information in it
but um you talk about uh
builder buy
that pretty much
really the same kind of conversation as
uh in-house versus outsourcing
yes and i've i
absolutely it does and and for us at the
bank uh you know the the builder by
a lot of that goes back to our it
department and what's available
and
do the does it have
the out of box um
services that they have everything
that's needed now that being said even
even on a lot of our systems that have
been bought and our platforms that have
been bought
there are gaps in between the systems
that normally an api would fill but it's
going to take too long to get an api so
we get a bot
and we get the bot in there and if the
api
you know was built then we'd just oh we
just turn off the bot and uh and so it
it just uh is a matter of whether that
platform is going to provide what you
need we have internal in our rpa coe we
had our um we had a platform that that
we used and uh we we didn't re-up
because we realized that
some of the
some of what we needed was not
in in the platform we were still doing a
lot of wasteful copying pasting copy and
pasting trying to get back and forth in
between our platforms and so we we uh we
built in-house on that um
ended up doing that
okay
uh
we have a few more questions if you have
time laura
okay um
i think one of the most important is
from alexis do you have suggestions on
getting management
to
buy into and adopt
lean principles and an rpa
yeah that is that is one of the most
challenging things
that uh that you're going to come up
against it really is i uh coming from
fedex fred smith
was
the person that drove their quality
program their lean six sigma baldridge
uh
he was the founder of the company he was
yes his employee number is number one at
fedex he was the founder of the company
and if mr smith said it is done then
that is done and and so uh that was very
spoiling for me because that's what you
need on a process improvement program
you need
that type of buy-in from the very top
or you can be wasting your time
and so uh one way though that you can
can do that and i've been
been challenged with some of that here
at the bank is
by showing what you can do this slower
right than having a mr smith say
this is what we're going to do
and part of your bonus by the way is
based on being able to achieve this and
so um what what i've done here at the
bank is is to is is a slower approach
but but just demonstrating what we do
with process improvements and so
it's it's coming along but it's far more
preferable to to have that upper
executive buy-in well they will listen
to your metrics you've absolutely got to
have your metrics in place so you get
those metrics in place and make sure
uh here's another
another point when you're going to get
that executive buy-in and try to to get
them aboard
make sure your metrics are respected by
the people in your company that the
executives respect
so
and by that i mean don't just pull an
hourly number from
you know
janey over here at the next desk or
whatever make sure it's from your your
hr your finance department
i meet monthly with our finance
department to make sure that these these
metrics are in line with what they view
as as being uh reasonable
and because you you've got to have that
if you get your buy-in with a bad metric
they're going to buy out you know and so
the metrics are are very very paramount
um another thing is to identify those
processes and those pain points that are
important to the executives and so
you've got to be able to identify those
pain points and you you approach those
pain points if if they're not important
to the executives the pain points that
you're relieving it doesn't really
matter it does matter but it's not going
to get you executive buy-in as far as if
you improve that
can i help and how can i demonstrate
with
metrics that can be validated that i
actually these process improvements
achieved uh what we expected them
achieving hopefully more
and and dinesh asks the related question
about how to convince a customer to
apply lean
um
and give up you know processes they
become comfortable with and
it seems to me that the same
same advice applies in terms of
you know showing them the benefits
focusing on solving pain points
um
how do you do that in the bank with with
your customers if you're going to
um change a process that's going to
affect how an external customer works
with you
i don't i haven't at the bank
done that because i deal with the
internal operations at x i did that
um and it it was a very interesting
process but um
basically one of the last process
improvement projects i did was with one
of fedex's largest medical suppliers and
um we were working through some
processes that needed improved and
worked
very collaboratively with them
both uh you know in calls and on-site
meetings with the customer
when we did that we
we taught them about the quality driven
management program we did process maps
we worked through the pain points we we
brainstormed and at the end of it it was
a very good collaborative uh engagement
and
at the start of it it was not you know
it was not but the the
customer had pains and we listened and
we addressed them
with the the process improvement program
and when we alleviated their pains that
again that was what was important to
them and that's what influenced them is
when we started they started seeing us
alleviate they their pain
then they then they listened and they
they adopted um what what we were doing
and integrated that and working with us
i i don't think if you i don't think
you're going to be real impactful but by
just um
preaching
you know
i think you've got to to demonstrate to
the customer you've got to show them a
value the same way you do with the
executives
in the place that they have pain
uh friday has a question
he's a consultant he's a coach in a lean
six sigma black belt
and
he asks if you have advice on
how to use six sigma in coaching people
you know it's uh it's interesting
because i got my training at the same
time i did lean training i did six sigma
although it was two separate
two separate training so all mine is
just kind of a big
mush posh in there but
you know but uh so in in six sigma you
know you have the demand processor which
is defined measure analyze improve
control and so uh
and even in my program you know it's six
sigma is joined into
uh the lean principles etc i take when
i'm going through a process improvement
i go through that that six sigma process
we've named it our own our own circular
you know inside the bank but it is that
defined measure analyze improve control
process of of where you
where you start looking at the process
and you've got to really study the the
process and and
one of the the issues that you come up
with when you start dealing with teams
on process improvement is they always
want to jump to the solution
and and you can't jump to the solution
you have to go through that that cycle
and those phases of really studying
what the process is and not jumping to a
solution because
the problem may not be the root cause
may not be the root cause you thought
when you when you initially started but
if you go through that that define
measure analyze improve control process
and that methodology of of
documenting the process reviewing the
process really getting to the root
causes that that's where you really get
your
your value
in there
yeah and when you talk about root causes
it reminds me of the old riddle about
you know
the truck that gets stuck under a bridge
because it's about one inch
lower than the clearance of the truck
um
and
you know whole
crews of emergency personnel and
construction workers come out and they
figure out well are we going to
cut into the bridge are we going to
disassemble the truck
and a little boy whispers to one of the
members i know
how to fix this
and
finally they turn to the little boy and
say
what would you do
and
little boy says i'd let some air out of
the tires of the truck
and that
really is
where you're
you have to say the root cause isn't the
fact that the bridge is too low for the
truck or the truck is too high for the
bridge
the the you know the the solution can be
found in
changing the dimensions you know the
parameters of the problem so you know
that kind of creative thinking is is
really important um
and you did mention documentation we did
have one question about what tools you
use for documentation um in your team
yeah for process maps um we use vizio
for process maps
and um
for other documentation like our process
definition document is just a word
template that we used a simple word
template we then we take the process
maps out of physio and embed them in
we use we use simple simple tools for
our uat template we have in excel
and you know that that's another tool
but we've looked at using different
tools but because we are so regulated
bank some of these uh
high functioning recording
tools etc that will produce your pdd and
your process maps all out there um
we were not comfortable with the
security on everything that was being
recorded quite frankly for a bank and so
um so we do use our simpler tools
makes sense um
so with that i'm going to
move on i think i apologize to anybody
whose questions we didn't get to
but we are
a little over time and
so i'm going to
move on to the next
phase
i did want to mention
that
we had some people who asked
uh about
um
how to find recordings of our webinars
previous webinars and i'd like to just
point people to our youtube channel
and i think i can put that
in the chat but if you go to our youtube
channel the webinars tend to be in the
simply learn live
section that you can do a search on
those
and a google search you can often find
them as well um
we'll do this one last poll for the
audience
um
and we ask about
the different things that folks in the
audience are interested in learning
so we'll start that
and i will mention one of the
courses that simple learn offers is in
fact introduction to robotic process
automation
so i will put a link to that into the
chat as well
and
give you the opportunity to
go to the
home page for that
let me get that into the chat here we go
and you'll also be able to find at our
website
courses in agile scrum lean principles
and that type of thing so
with that
feel the poll results
people today no surprise are interested
in the business and project management
domain
but also data science ai
and product management
so with that said and with about 40
percent of the audience saying they'd
like to start right away
um
please do come to our website or
if you have specific questions about
um courses or that type of thing you can
email
the contact information from the
invitation you received i'm going to
mention laura's book which is coming out
in august of 2022.
laura do you want to describe
what lean mission is about
uh it's the book i wish i had when i was
standing up the process improvement and
rpa programs at the bank it's not
theoretical
it's uh it's the kind of information of
where do we start start your list you
know that kind of thing
what do we look at what are the
different phases that you go through in
the process improvement and also in rpa
so uh a hands-on book very practical
book
keep an eye out for that it's been
coming out and i'm going to put a
the link that's at the bottom for
laura's linkedin
that's in the chat now as well so you
can just click on that and with that i'd
like to to say thank you to laura for a
really marvelous conversation it's
as always a pleasure
speaking with you and learning from you
my pleasure stuart i enjoyed it as
always
and um i'd like to
let the audience know that we will be
having another webinar next tuesday
on a different topic but one that
should interest
everybody here and maybe all of their
friends
here is
a session with carmen bryant who was the
director of marketing at indeed and she
will be able to share with with you
how to work the the job boards like
indeed and glassdoor and that type of
thing
to get the best results
make the most out of your job search so
if you are
looking for a job or if you are
considering a job shift
or if you know people who are please let
them know about this webinar and the
link is in the chat
um
as i mentioned we have i'll do it one
more one last time i'll put the
link to the robotic process automation
course
and
with that i think we
conclude our webinar today so thank you
laura again and thank you to everybody
for being here please follow us on
our social media channels at simplylearn
on facebook and twitter
we're on linkedin
under simplylearn and
we look forward to welcoming you into
the simply learn learner community as
well as seeing you at future simply
learn webinars so thanks again and
thank you laura
you're welcome stuart have a great day
okay and that concludes our webinar
today
you